as with every Tarantino film once upon a
time in Hollywood is rich with
storytelling depth and meaning
especially as the film reaches its
climax now that the movies out it's time
to dig deep into the ending let's get
the biggest development of the ending
out of the way Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood is a movie in which the Manson
Family murders didn't happen the way
they did in real life it's clear from
clips visit to the spawn Movie Ranch
that Charles Manson's commune is up to
something devious but when it comes time
to commit the infamous murderers on
Cielo Drive on the night of August 8th
historical fact gives way to fiction one
drug-fueled decision to change plans and
try to murder Rick Dalton creates a
ripple effect Sharon Tate and her
friends survived that night and three
key members of Manson's family do not
though the film ends before it can
explore the full extent of this ripple
effect it's safe to assume that the
black cloud created by the Manson
murders in 1969 was changed in a number
of key ways Joan Didion famously wrote
that the night Sharon Tate died was the
night the 1960s ended the decade was
about to end anyway
but perhaps Rick and Cliff's acts of
self-defense were enough to keep the
feelings of the 1960's alive in
Hollywood for at least a little longer
the last shot of Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood shows us Rick having torched
Susan Atkins in his pool during the
attack on his house being invited up to
Sharon Tate's home for drinks it's the
realization of a fantasy rick has been
nurturing ever since he figured out that
the hottest director in town Roman
Polanski and his rising star wife were
his neighbors - Rick they're the people
who can get him in - all the best
Hollywood circles the people who can
resurrect his struggling career the film
offers us no promises as to what lies in
store for Rick's professional life going
forward but within minutes of meeting
Jay Sebring he's already bragging about
the night's events at worst he's going
to become a hit at various Hollywood
parties for a while at best
Rick could end up with everything from a
role in Polanski's next film to a
brand-new TV series even though Rick
gets to brag about the events cliff
takes the brunt of the Manson family's
attack which includes
bumps bruises and a knife embedded in
his hip still he's cheerful as the
ambulance takes him away
promising Rick that he'll live to fight
another day once upon a time in
Hollywood establishes early on that
cliffs reputation is in the gutter since
he likely had a hand in his wife's
suspicious death it's hard to believe
everyone would forget about that because
he fought off attackers at Rick's house
if anything it will likely add to his
reputation as a violent man in some
circles however in other circles it
could also speak to his reputation as a
badass with a long career in stunt work
maybe retellings of the event will help
make people like Randy more open to
cliffs whole vibe I don't dig him and I
don't dig the vibe he brings on a set
the bedrock of Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood is ultimately the friendship
between cliff and Rick something which
ends up transcending any dynamic as
simple as leading man and stunt double
these men are in some ways closer than
brothers and that relationship is the
through line that carries the film in
the final minutes of the film it's very
clear that Rick feels indebted to cliff
for saving his life no matter what
happens from this point on cliff and
Rick are stronger and closer than ever
at the time of her death Sharon Tate's
acting career consisted of only a
handful of film roles and a few stints
on TV most notably a recurring role on
The Beverly Hillbillies still as once
upon a time in Hollywood shows she was a
talented actor with a bright future it's
impossible to guess what Sharon Tate's
full professional future would hold in a
world in which she's still alive once
upon a time seems to hint that the best
is still to come for Tate it's this
bittersweet notion a world in which Tate
is allowed to live on that most sticks
with you as you leave the theater
because of the mythology that sprung up
around her and death the potential life
she never got to have carries even more
weight even before the Manson family
begins its attack at the end of the film
there are plenty of key differences that
establish the alternate universe in
which the film takes place the biggest
difference is obviously that the Tate
murders never take place but the
historical discrepancies
throughout the film established that the
world has changed even before that crime
is avoided what else changes in this new
timeline Tarantino has established one
in which tape doesn't die and Polanski
doesn't come home to a crime scene
what does Joan Didion write about if not
the Manson murders and subsequent trial
does Bruce Lee whose legend also looms
large in the film somehow get to survive
his own tragic early death just four
years later do the Beatles ever learn
about Manson's strange interpretation of
their lyrics no check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]